apport au basque c'est la désolation des
débris partout des objets de la vie
quotidienne projetés très loin des
maisons et à travers ses débris des
résidents comme Peter à la recherche de
souvenirs
des objets à l'effigie du Canadien des
photos de sa famille et sa maison
complètement dévastée il ne reste plus
rien de son paradis juché sur les caps
sa femme ne veut plus habiter sur le
bord de l'océan dit-il ni même la
voisine plusieurs résidents craignent
maintenant la mer il leur faudra de
l'aide pour traverser cette épreuve
et l'aide elle arrive un camionneur de
Saint-Jean a profité d'un transport de
voiture neuve vers port-au-basque pour
ravitailler les sinistrés chaque voiture
a été remplie de vêtements de bouteilles
d'eau et de nourriture et cela en moins
de 24 heures
nous sommes des terre-neviens dit-il
c'est ce que les terre ne vient font
Hélène habite port-au-basse elle s'est
fait un devoir devenir prêter main forte
au sinistre
j'étais à la maison me demandant quoi
faire pour aider alors j'ai dit oui tout
de suite
le premier ministre de la province est
venu constater les dégâts dans la
municipalité au plus de 80 maisons ont
été détruites en découvrant une photo
d'un mariage auquel le ministre de
l'Industrie a assisté
le gouvernement promet d'être présent
même si la reconstruction peut prendre
des années
bien des maisons ne sont pas assurées et
celles qui le sont ne le sont peut-être
pas alors d'un événement de la sorte
explique un blue Fury le gouvernement
sera là pour eux et j'ai confiance que
le fédéral suivra une centaine de
soldats sont arrivés à Terre-Neuve
labradores sont en attente de
déploiement elle devrait être sur le
terrain dès que ce sera possible
explique l'officier de l'armée
en attendant Peter doit rebâtir sa
confiance en la mer comme beaucoup de
résidents qui craignent qu'elle ne se
déchaîne à nouveau ici Marie-Josée
paquet de comoradio-canada port au
basque